the world
[Music]
foreign
thank you those of you who are joining
us online we appreciate you being here
as well
um so I'm thankful
that fall weather is finally beginning
to come here and hit us here in Texas I
can't even tell you
especially this morning waking up and
I'm like oh it feels just a little bit
cool and the the days are gonna get
cooler this week and actually put on
jeans today where I can actually feel
comfortable wearing jeans and not hot
and sticky so oh and then this is the
Time of the Season where chili lives
love chili oh my gosh can't wait for
that stuff to happen
so anyway speaking of Chile we are
actually having in a couple of weeks
um a couple of with some East uh no
excuse me wrong season some holiday
um
Halloween thank you I had the H word in
my head and that's not what my mouth
wanted to say so I appreciate this is
there so anyway so but yes we're gonna
be doing our Trunk or Treat
um event that's going to happen in the
last Friday of the month
um so please make sure that you
participate in that and we're gonna of
course call this stuff for the kids and
if you want to have your car there bring
candy all the things all the things we
did have a sign up sheet back there but
I don't see that but if you let Brittany
know she will most definitely add you to
that list I'm sure
so anyway
um without also with that being said we
next Sunday we are not going to be
having our normal service at five five
o'clock
almost at least the wrong time by five
o'clock so we're gonna be celebrating
with uh Pleasant Valley uh they're
having their 160th anniversary which I
still think that's amazing 160 years
that they've been
um in Pleasant Valley so that starts at
11 o'clock
um they're also be doing like a barbecue
lunch at the end so stick around for
that to kind of participate with them
with that as well and then one last
thing
Miss minor you mind staying up for a
second
so we have talked about the t-shirts
today is the last day to order this
t-shirt do you mind turning around
giving
says the table dot org on the back there
we go look it doesn't look amazing
doesn't it
how yeah yeah
so
I yes Gary really likes him glad he does
anyway so um with that being said
um if you wouldn't mind joining us in
prayer we'll get started with worship
Lauren thank you so much for bringing us
together
thank you for this space thank you for
the people in this room
thank you for the votes of her joining
online but by hearing this hand on my
voice
I pray you open our hearts and our minds
to worship tonight
they're going to be shared to it this
evening
I pray that you just help us to
um
just be able to relax and be present
help us just to be able to connect with
you
I pray that you help us gives us the
strength
the
the patience the peace that we're going
to need coming up in this next week with
all the different things that we may
have just weighing on our hearts
with all these things across Enterprise
amen
you guys want to go ahead and stand to
your feet we cannot start whoa hello
Echo we cannot start this first song
without you guys you'll have to be all
in with us it's one of our absolute
favorites and it's kind of what we
started off the table with our very
first Sunday way back when and we're
coming up on an anniversary so as we go
into this song Let's just celebrate all
that God has done and continues to do in
our community all right
ring the bells this time
[Music]
more than what the hell is
foreign
[Music]
Despair and loving more than what the
hell is
[Music]
ring the bells
then what the hell
[Music]
ring the bells
foreign
[Music]
all right you kiddos are dismissed to
your classes and we're gonna go ahead
and step into the prayers of the people
and Caitlyn's going to lead us in that
so you guys read along with her
for the city of Sachse Texas and for
every city and community and all of
those who live in them we pray to you
for the Good Earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and will to conserve
it we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
we pray to you
for the old and the sick
for the Widow and orphan for the injured
and suffering we pray to you
for the poor and oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and for all who remember
and care for them we pray to you
Lord we know that you love us and you
hear us so we lift these names and
situations up to you
foreign
[Music]
for the names and moments we have spoken
aloud and for those we have kept in our
hearts we pray to you that they may have
life and life
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence
amen
[Music]
the empty filled the wounded
by together
the poor are blessed the weary rest we
will Dance Forever
[Music]
the blinded Thief who changed our free
doubtful now believe her the outcasts
know the orphan hope
you heard my
redeemer behold
he hopes
[Music]
he's making all things new
the last return the voiceless heard the
mourner now rejoicing
Mountain shade the world away
creation of composing
untrue
the song has found its singer the
darkness
[Music]
we've been struck down
we're not destroyed
[Music]
in tears
we've been struck down we're not
destroyed
[Music]
my eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
to be
[Applause]
[Music]
he's making all things
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
my way
[Music]
that I'm gonna sing
in the middle of the storm
louder and louder You're Gonna Hear My
Praises
[Music]
hope will arise
I raise a Hallelujah
with everything inside of me
[Music]
in the middle of the mystery
Hallelujah
[Music]
I missed it
is to fit the king is alive and I'm
gonna sing
in the middle of the storm
louder and louder
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
presence of my enemies
[Applause]
[Music]
louder
I'm gonna sing in the middle of the
storm
louder
[Music]
[Applause]
is defeated the king is alive
[Music]
okay
I raise
you
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
yes God we come to you tonight and
gather together knowing and believing
God that you are here with us in our
midst
God that whatever battles we're fighting
that you're with us
whatever storms we're walking through
God that you're with us
[Music]
that you don't let go of us
you don't give up on us
you don't turn your back
God we hold on to the truth
that nothing can separate us from the
love of God
[Music]
no height nor depth
nothing pulls us away from you God
so we sink into that tonight God we
anchor into that truth We Believe
that you are a god of love
you are Emmanuel God With Us
[Music]
would we sense you God as we go
throughout our days
whatever comes God would we feel that
presence
anchoring us
to who we were created to be to who you
are
with circumstances not pull us one way
or the other God but would we be
anchored into you
[Music]
and to the love of God
thank you
[Music]
foreign
God give us hearts that are ready to
hear anything that you have for us
anything that you may be speaking any
truths that we need to hang on to God
we're ready to hear them
we want you to fill us up
[Music]
it's in your name that we pray all these
things
foreign
[Music]
I am on
welcome to the table as you can see I am
not Brett
foreign
my name is Karen Miner and I am part of
the Elder leadership team here at the
table Brett is not here tonight because
his grandmother recently passed away so
he is with family this weekend so just
please be praying for them and their
family this coming week he will be back
next week but in the meantime we have a
treat tonight we are wrapping up our
series that we've been in for several
weeks called unclean which is based on a
book by the same name unclean written by
Christian Psychologist Richard Beck and
so the messages in the series have been
about a main theme which is discussed
psychology which as a refresher that's
that impulse Instinct within us that
recoils if there's like moldy food a rat
running by or a spider or anything that
just makes you go ew
um and that's that's fine for things
that are things
um the danger is when we start to do
that with people or with people groups
um and so
uh in many ways this Series has been
about the love of Jesus and how the love
of Jesus moves toward it does not recoil
from people you see that all over the
scriptures where Jesus did things like
eat with people that the religious
leaders said were unclean or who were
Sinners when Jesus reaches out and
touches the man with Leprosy before
Jesus heals him not after so this
Embrace and and leaning towards people
versus keeping your distance afraid of
being you know pulled into whatever
their state is what have you so uh one
of the things one of my favorite things
about being part of this community is
our uh value for being communal and
being inclusive and that includes
hearing from various people in our
community so we thought tonight it would
be great as we wrap up the series to
hear from some of the people in our
community how the message struck them
what are the things that stood out and
so without further Ado because I want
them to have as much time as possible to
share because they've got great stuff
would you help me welcome up Jamie
Michael Christian and Megan come on up
[Applause]
thank you
there you go
first chair yes yes yes
all right first of all thank you so so
much for saying yes to this this takes
courage and vulnerability to be willing
to be seen and share and so just thank
you for for being willing to do this
so first off just to help everybody to
get to know you just going down the line
can you share your name preferred
pronouns and how you got connected to
the table
um yeah my name is Michael Alvarez I use
any pronouns are fine I really like they
but I'm cool with all of them and um
I've been going to the table for about a
year now um it was just a quick Google
search like LGBT affirming churches but
um yeah I got really lucky because I
haven't had to try any other ones
sounds cool great thanks
hi I'm Jamie Holloman they them I also
found the table via the same kind of
online search around January
my name is Christian Gray Herring I go
by he him I found the table same
internet search find everything on the
internet and my wife on the internet you
know all the same stuff clearly it's
working for you
and I'm Megan is she her we've been here
about two months so very fresh to the
table
welcome
and jumping right in
all right so first question and the way
we're going to do this is they will
chime in if a question resonates with
them and they have something to share
about it so not everybody will answer
every question but you will definitely
hear from everyone
all right
as we went through the series did you
find yourself mostly reflecting on how
church people made you feel unclean
or how you have perhaps viewed others as
unclean or was it an even split
anyone want to jump in on that one
um yeah so
like immediately I like being Michael so
I I like thought about just growing up
how that's something that's been like
pointed at me like my whole life whether
it's because of like the color of my
skin or the fact that I was more
effeminate like within my own circles or
when I did come out as queer
um like that whole journey but as the
series progressed I was like wow maybe I
am part of the problem too just because
um I started to realize that I myself
had been putting these labels on other
people as well and I like I guess in
being like a victim of like discussed
psychology like I had put up these
barriers that were the same weapons like
against me
I think
I think starting out I probably thought
mostly about how maybe I had
made other people feel uncomfortable I
remember this Vivid story of being in
like a youth group at church and very
passionate
teaching about who you're around and how
those other people can tarnish your you
know your walk or your
um
your witness that was the word the
witness that you you have to other
people and it didn't come to
it did it wasn't just
being around like doing the bad things
it was being around the bad people and
so I remember this one time and it's I
hate that I did it but there was one
person that
um I was I had a really good
relationship we were talking but my
church was very pushy about this whole
topic and then I ended up basically
saying I'm so sorry I can't be your
friend anymore because you're not a
Christian and it was just that's how it
had affected and and made me the and and
my people the group that I could only
spend time with which is you know
completely antithetical to the way that
Jesus lived hmm
kind of that Fortress Yeah mentality
yeah
thank you yeah as the series went on I
started thinking about how they're
connected and how the impulse to other
other groups to make other groups
unclean maybe stems from the desires and
or a need to make myself pure right and
so
um if I'm not willing to kind of look at
myself and ask how I am
um viewing people as unclean as not
worthy of reaching out across divides
then I'm almost by necessity going to
put that onto another group of people
and so that that work kind of really
starts with me or else it becomes a
vicious circle
yeah
what any other thoughts on that one
yeah I think for me it started off my
answer would be neither in that there
like I kind of stepped back and it was
more of
um looking at how the church treats
people who are unclean without
considering how I fit into it and so
this question and I think that's part of
being an Indian gray mate right like I'm
the protector I'm the one who's gonna
like save the day and protect the
unclean and all that
um but I think there was a definite the
series was really helpful in
making me pause and do self-reflection
in going okay I'm oftentimes very aware
and wanting to protect the unclean but
seeing instances where
for example like when it's a person who
doesn't have the power or privilege
right like it's easy for me to want to
be like oh we need to right this wrong
and take care of them it's really hard
though for me to then not view those who
have the power and privilege and who may
be using it for Injustice did not put
them in the unclean camp and somehow I
justify that mentally in in being okay
because it's all about solving Injustice
as a but in reality I'm doing the very
same thing so I think this series was
really good in reflecting on that yeah
yeah that's good thank you
all right let's talk about church
upbringing Christian you talked a little
bit about about that already
um were you raised in a church
environment that tended to use a lot of
Purity metaphors when talking about the
sins of people or about groups of people
and how did that play out in the church
culture
oh yes you know Jesus washes our sin
away and makes us white as snow and
those were like phrases that I I heard
all the time growing up and so I think
it promoted
um very much in evangelism right that
we're this inner group that needs to
um share this message that's going to
lead others to being just as pure as we
are
um it emphasized that salvation was by
Grace
um to the point of which
I think it minimized any sense of
self-growth right because I'm already
clean Jesus already made me clean
therefore I don't have to do anything to
or need to do any growth as in being a
person and so I think that the Purity
metaphors
did a disservice and not really
challenging
spiritual growth and formation yeah
I think attached to that
um I think there's an aspect of being a
kid who grew up in church culture in
like the 90s there was I think it was a
book that came out that was titled like
not even a hint and the idea was
basically like you don't want there to
be any chance that anybody at all is
going to think that there's anything
about you that is like sinful dirty
unclean that sort of thing but thinking
about the verse that Brett continued to
refer to in the series about Jesus
hanging with tax collectors and sinners
Jesus had lots of hints like there were
lots of ways in which it was like by
hanging out with those people there was
a hint that he was
dirty and unclean but he wasn't so it
doesn't have anything to do with the
proximity but that's what you can
translate it to
um I just I think it's so funny like I
so I grew up in like the Church of
Christ and um so
um yeah uh that's it
so I think
I guess like as a kid you're kind of
like shielded from all like the nasty
parts of like your church and your youth
group and stuff but I remember like I
was super involved in like youth group
and everything
um like love like the youth mystery I
went to like every event and everything
my family was like in there but um it
was like in Middle School when
um I was like I was not an athlete but I
was in Fellowship of Christian athletes
and
um my uh uh what's it called the
president of our club was one of my best
friends from the from the church Allison
and Allison went on to uh she was like
number one Ally ever and um I didn't
even know I was like queer at the time
she probably knew but
um but anyways she had um started a GSA
which might have been like a little
young but you know where can you give
the acronym oh sorry yeah so a gay
straight Alliance club which is just
kind of like
yeah I guess Reliance um LGBT rights
um all that
um club we don't like now that I think
about him like what do we even do we're
at eighth grade but um but you know it
was nice to see it
um anyways
um I think the first time that I had
kind of like witnessed like I guess one
of the like uglier sides of my church
was that like as soon as she like
started that like
like the Elders of our church like
pressured her into being like you can't
be like
part of like you can't be the president
of FCA and be a part of the GSA like
that's not and I was like
oh like wow like and at that point I
didn't even know that that like applied
to me yet but that was I guess like the
first time that I had like
seen like Purity culture that you like
used against me like
like did Jesus not sit with them like
you know like that and that was always
something that kind of like felt wrong
to me like it wasn't right
and I always tell people like
like growing up in in that kind of
environment like people like especially
other queer people that like I don't
know that are outside of this community
they always ask me like how can you be
like Christian well I've never felt like
unloved by Jesus I've always felt like
like it was
certain like Christian bodies that had
like a problem against me you were able
to separate that yeah I was able to
separate that and I'm so glad I like I
was able to but
um I always think back to so Allison's
mom their family ended up leaving the
church of Christ
um but her mom one time she was our
youth group like one of the ministers
and she did this like one lesson that
was kind of about like Purity that that
was so beautiful to me and that was one
of the only things that I remember from
like being a part of that church like as
far as like actual scripture or whatever
but um or
um she did this thing where she put like
two vials of like water
and she was talking about her brother so
and she was just she was like my brother
is a felon
and she put like a drop of dye in there
my brother lied to me a lot
she was like my brother
hurt my mom like this and that and then
she put another drop in the other one
that was like
but I haven't loved my brother a lot you
know like it was just stuff like that
and she said which one is like worse
and
we were like
he's bad but take away the lesson was
that like
like none of that like matters like
in the fact that like like we aren't you
can't like pick and choose like who's
like sin is like worse or anything like
we are all like sinning and we're all
like having to strive towards like
something greater so
like I don't know I just thought it was
so like that's one thing I took away
from the church that was like
amidst all that like Church of Christ
like craziness Miss uh Lou she taught me
that and it kind of like is something
that I carried with me that was kind of
like part of my shield is like I am not
any worse than you but yeah yeah
yeah just real quickly a few like Words
yeah so well first of all Purity
metaphors were rampant and my church
environment and
um some words that came up for me were
exclusion
um because that's what Purity laws do
right they draw those boundaries
um and they not only give you a reason
to exclude people but almost a moral
imperative too because there that that
impurity is going to infect the rest of
the people so there's this like active
push out of exclusion and then also just
a lot of fear um it puts a lot of like
emphasis on personal piety and and it's
very individualistic and so it draws
your thinking away from Community
um kind of broader broader picture I'm
sorry broader picture things
um systemic Injustice systemic sins to
just like this personal level of I need
to make sure that I am white as snow and
don't have don't have any ampurity in
myself
yeah
thank you
we're going to stick with Purity culture
for a minute
many Evangelical churches throughout the
90s and early 2000s emphasize something
that has come to be known as Purity
culture
that is a very high value for remaining
sexually pure until marriage it seems to
have negatively impacted many people I
mean the stories I've heard and probably
many of you have heard have been mostly
negative
were any of you impacted by Purity
culture we've heard a little a little
bit of that
how have you thought about sexuality in
a way that finds a path between anything
goes versus any sexual activity outside
of marriage renders you dirty and impure
forever
anything
um I tend to think in extremes my brain
just I it's probably like my OCD like
legitimate anxiety disorder OCD stuff
that tends to think in extremes and so
um again being a kid that grew up in the
90s with the Ikea State and goodbye book
and all of that other fun stuff I
it was it was interesting because it
wasn't for me it didn't translate just
as
sex outside of marriage is wrong and you
shouldn't do that it translated to
attraction towards anybody is wrong like
because that could be moving towards
that bad thing and so for me like it
created a whole bunch of Shame just
around even just attraction and finding
that balance for it took many years
before I finally found I think a healthy
balance in that
yeah I almost brought my uh Purity card
as like you know example of back in the
day for realization yes um
attention
I uh I've definitely read the Ikea
stating goodbye but I um didn't drink
the Kool-Aid so much that I also didn't
read the Lesser known title I gave
dating a chance
um it was the rebuttal to it that uh
obviously was still part of the Purity
culture just a little nuanced
um but you know I think in some ways it
was it did have some good things for me
right it made me think about like what
is the purpose of dating it
um
you know I avoided probably a lot of
pain that others might have experienced
I I don't know but so I
but in the end I do think it's it was
really problematic right whether it be
leading towards judgmentalism or I I
didn't really date a whole lot and got
to my late 20s and then had this
oh my gosh everybody else knows what
they're doing and I don't
um and that I felt really dumb and that
feeling of dumb then led to really a lot
of stress
um thankfully I found a really good sex
therapist who was able to help me
process in a freeing
place to be able to and she wasn't quick
to be like oh you're just like
religiously repressed and or your
chakras off I had that at another lady
tell me it um but it said she was it was
a place where I could just talk and and
here and be able to process
um some of the the stuff that I just
didn't know that people I felt like
people my age didn't know because I was
the good Christian girl who didn't do
any of that and and had waited and um
thankfully my a good friend of mine in
the youth group she was very vocal in
saying when I have when I get married
I'm gonna have the best sex ever and
it's gonna be so good and I think that
was really helpful in that like because
I also knew like women my age who that's
not their reality right even though they
did all of the things that they were
promised that would lead to good sex It
ultimately those feelings of Shame
weren't able to be separated and so
um somehow I ended up in a weird middle
uh ground but
um yeah that's my story yeah
yeah I experience pretty culture not as
just kind of the ethic that you should
wait until marriage to have sex but it's
also a lot of ideas around like
civilizational decline you know like
sexual immoralities is gonna like you
know that's the reason why our country's
going down the tubes um and that's a lot
of pressure to put on Teenage bodies and
sexualities
um but it's also connected to gender
roles and all sorts of things so it's
more than just like you know the kind of
a traditional thing of wait until you're
married to have sex but one story for me
is so I I went to an Evangelical college
and in my junior year I was dating
somebody dating a man
um not cool
um and so this is very kind of under the
radar
um and
um in the course of this relationship
he's actually assaulted me
um and just the the isolation and the
Purity culture like kept me from feeling
like I think I could seek help and so it
kept me in this bubble because first of
all I was having sex which is wrong and
also there's like the sexuality thing so
a couple of different things kind of
conspiring to just keep me locked in
this kind of private space with this
trauma that I had no ability to process
and you know really it really took me
into like some dark places and stuff
because the Purity culture prized like
um you know Purity and sacrifice over
mercy and loving people just where
wherever their situation is and so that
kind of in that one instance just for me
kind of speaks to how this winds up
hurting real people
um and in ways that maybe you're
unintended maybe are intended but it
yeah because of because of this Purity
impulse I was not protected or able to
seek help
hmm
I think it's just like it's so upsetting
because I don't think I've met I feel
like like two I don't know the
statistics but like two out of three
like other queer men or like people that
I meet have like been sexually assaulted
and like that was like
like I was like 18. and it was just
something that like I could never talk
about and as soon as it like had
happened like I kept that with me for
like three years before I said anything
else like after that like sex was like
not something that was
like that it should have been it was
like a Battleground you know that that
and then I feel like Purity culture kind
of led me to like
like I think that I could have had to
deal with it like all by myself because
I was like more afraid
of letting my parents know that I had
not only like premarital sex but it's
like what the man like you know it's it
was
so crazy and that's and when it sucked
was like when I did tell my parents it
like the first thing that I did see on
my their face was like disgust because
of like the
the you know like the I don't even know
the words but uh yeah instead of like
what I was expecting to like get and I
feel like
things like that take like years and
years and years and years to like
breakthrough
where as like
I don't know it's just it's just
terrible and I I know that
like as I say this like it's happening
to so many other like not even just like
queer men and women but like just
everyone
yeah and unfortunate that church should
be where you can share
and be met with mercy and compassion and
support and how that's so often not the
case
Carrie can you read the last part of
that question it was really good the
second half yeah
how have you thought about sexuality in
a way that finds a path between anything
goes versus any sexual activity outside
of marriage renders you dirty and impure
forever
um I think and this is where I went back
to Brett's metaphor language because a
lot of the metaphors that I heard around
sexuality were like
um The Rose That Gets trampled
um or it's like the white wedding gown
you know that gets like stained with a
Scarlet Letter and I guess I want to
take a moment to just name that I think
these burdens like are unequally
distributed to people raised as women
um so I just want to name that as I was
using the bridal dress metaphor but
um The Heart Is Right that like you lose
a piece of your heart each time you know
that you're with somebody and so those
metaphors are like all going in in this
kind of One Direction so I've started
trying to think about other metaphors
for sex for sexuality
um and the first one that I came up with
was the parable of the talents
um so Jesus like tells the story about
you know one servant or he gives them
all like this gift which is I think what
our sexualities are is gifts from God
and one servant just like buries it in
the ground and like doesn't do anything
with it and then the other like puts it
to good use right and like
um investing is is overly economical but
it's that idea of like
um using it for good and growing the
gift and so you know maybe that's a
metaphor that that I've been thinking
about also like hospitality and
I think I think there can be real
connections between like embodiment and
and theology I don't want to get like
very graphic but um I think that like
sex is a way to learn more about myself
and about God I think breaking down this
like holy spirit versus like evil body
you know dichotomy that we get presented
with that like sex is sacred to and as
part of life is is part of
um knowing god better
um and I've experienced that and also
finally just as like metaphors for like
creativity of what it means to be a
human so this is very much in process
for me um but that's why I wanted to
come back to this question thank you to
get ideas from other people
um because yeah I'm still working
through it but I think maybe the
metaphor level is a place that I have
thought about sorry trying something I
like the word that you said hospitality
and so in processing out of Purity
culture I read many books and one of
those was Shameless by Navi Bulls Weber
and in it she talks about having a sex
ethic and she talks about how the World
Health Organization you know their sex
ethic is made up of consent enthusiastic
consent and mutuality right the pleasure
of both
um and she says though to have a
Christian ethic you have to have those
but add on concern and she tied what she
means by concern is you know tying into
that idea of loving God and loving
others being aware of the needs and the
the person that is that sex is happening
with that it's not just a willing body
it's a whole person and so I really
appreciated
um that sort of metaphor of hospitality
and sex yeah
good we get to move on yeah
um
all right two weeks ago we talked about
how moral personal and communal
boundaries are vitally important and yet
can also become walls that dehumanize
others
share a brief story of what loving
boundaries have looked like in your own
life
um
I was just like talking to Megan I'm
like I feel like I've I've been pretty
good like in my life about centering
boundaries with like people that are
like outside of my circle I'm like you
can't talk to me like that like you like
you know I am able to walk away from
situations that like I know that I don't
deserve to be in but I've come to like
realize since my time of like being here
at the table and especially with like my
Wiley like
uh the group but um your meet up shout
out to the Meetup I have problems
setting boundaries with my family
um and um
just like uh recently like
um
so my family is currently going through
like a little World War III right now
just because
um of some conflict between like my
parents and my grandparents and like
where
um I like stand
um in there and
for me
my father has always kind of been like
this like body of like
of like
um where I've faced a lot of like
discussed psychology where I faced a lot
of like just like other mint from like
the rest of my siblings because of like
my queerness and all that
um and just like other stuff like
physical abuse like the list like is
long but
um
in the last year since I started coming
to the table there's been like a
physical like distance like my whole
family moved to California
and it's just me and my sisters out here
in Texas and
um
I loved it I loved it and it's so much
easier to like love your family from
like a boundary but
um like a physical boundary and that's
been cool but
they're during like this hard time with
my family
um my father is like dealing with like a
lot of like
like I've never seen my dad like this
emotional it like
uh from anger or like sadness and all of
that but my dad
I haven't like one thing that has been
kind of like scary to me that I've been
thinking about since uh one of Brad's
sermons in the series is that like
I feel like like bad that I don't
have
um
like
like my father crying should like phase
me you know my father crying should like
make me feel something I should like
care about it and
when I I guess it's been like one of
those boundaries that I put up just to
protect myself
is that
I want to
I want to like separate my emotions like
from my family and and I think like even
more so I want to be like a nasty person
about it like on the inside really
um but
so I've been battling with that a lot
since I've been coming over here and
like trying to be like a better person
and stuff is that like is me rejecting
my father the person that has hurt me
throughout my whole life like is that
being like unchristian-like like should
I welcome my like what was I think
that's right side he said something
about like loving your
son or your father isn't always like oh
like my dad bought me a new car I love
you like you know it's it's not that
sometimes it's like looking at someone
who's like failed you consistently and
being like
I forgive you
and I've been like
that's been like one of the biggest
things that I've like are the hardest
things for me to like accept is that
like how
can I forgive my father and especially
when he's like and I'm faced with a very
realist Choice when he's like looking at
me and like
crying and like he he misses me he's
texting me you know this isn't that
but
um when Brett was talking about
boundaries I think one of the things
that kind of like stuck with me is that
like you can look at somebody and be mad
at them and you can still wish them like
all the best
and
I think that's and and I don't think
that I should feel bad that that's all
that I can do right now
and um it's a process and I think
like
maybe one day maybe one day I can like
open up my arms and like ex you know
like let down that boundary but right
now I think it's okay that
um it's okay and for everybody to have
these boundaries of people that like you
know you once
like loved or whatever
um
yeah yeah thank you I think it adds on
the complexity when that
the boundaries from learned experience
I know that like you're talking very
deep and this is not a very deep example
but this is Christian with farming let
me explain
um Christian and Dan has lots of
chickens that produce lots of eggs and
they very graciously would bring us eggs
when they would come to visit well the
first time great second time
he boiled some eggs and he gets to work
to eat his boiled egg and it was rotten
and it was gross
um and so every time he would have
another egg he would be like oh oh I
think this one's rotten and he would
throw it away because he couldn't like
it was this like thought of this is a
rotten egg and that an experience was so
horrible it tainted every other egg and
so the man won't accept any more farm
eggs which are really good farm eggs
um you know we have to get the plain
white ones from Costco
um
anyway but I think that like when it's a
learned experience I think that those
the natural like putting up of walls
like it's much harder to tear down and I
don't know for me
and I had a family member who
who
created a little bit of a toxic a lot of
a toxic environment and in
I wanted to protect other family members
from the situation which caused lots of
bitterness in me and I kept praying
please help me forgive this person
because I needed to in order for our
family to function and
um I finally realized that
I couldn't forgive like it was something
that couldn't come from me and so my
prayer began to change asking God to
teach me how to love them and it I don't
know how it happened but it forgiveness
eventually happened and and the
relationship isn't perfect it's still
messy
um but I think that
I think I have to hold on to that and
force myself to go to that place and be
or be willing to go eventually to that
place
because I believe in a god who's all
about Redemption right and that means
that if he's about Redemption then then
people are redeemable even the people
who I have the hardest time wanting to
allow them to be redeemed
thank you
I really hate to cut this short but we
are out of time
um please feel free to talk to these
folks I mean clearly so much good stuff
here and as I believe many of you would
have Reflections thank you so much you
sharing just enriches our community it
broadens it it broadens our perspectives
we get to hear other
um just experiences and we're better for
it so thank you thank you so much can
you guys give them a hand as they make
their way back
thank you
so so good all right so
as we come to the table of communion
tonight
may we do so with Open Hearts and with
the reminder that each one of you each
one of us
are so loved
we are already accepted we are already
embraced let's live from a place of
being already loved by a very very good
and gracious God so let me do our Celtic
invitation to the table
this is the table not of the church but
of the Lord and it is made ready for
those who love him and for those who
want to love him more
so come you who have much faith and you
who have little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long you who have
tried to follow and you who have failed
come because it is the Lord who invites
and it is his will that those who want
to meet him should meet him here come to
the table
thank you
good
[Music]
foreign
God Made You
to messed up
if you've been raised a southern belle
born and bred for show and tell but you
but you lie down feeling never good
enough
and I'm so sorry
for how it's been
broken artists
with broken pants
are pride
and call it truth
sorry no one explained Jesus to you
[Music]
if you heard a knock on your front door
it's all you found on the porch was a
pastor who just wanted
be right
[Music]
if you really want pray to him you never
make sure he's listening because
just forgive
I did last night
and I'm so sorry
for what you heard
broken poets
silly words
[Music]
saved us
we call it truth
sorry no one explained Jesus
[Music]
all he really wants is you
I'm so sorry
for all the wrong
a broken singers
with broken songs
we paid our pride
and call it truth
sorry no one explained Jesus
[Music]
sorry no one explained Jesus to you
oh thank you guys so much for just being
vulnerable and coming up here that's why
I get the same things that care just
shared this is just one of those special
moments when we get to kind of reflect
on what's been shared and I have my own
personal thoughts on the things that
we've been learning but it's amazing to
hear it and just drives it home a lot
deeper when I get to hear how it's
impacting from other people
I learned so much so I appreciate you
guys for just coming up here being
vulnerable sharing that with us thank
you caring for
um moderating that and everything like
that so okay just a couple quick
reminders
um like I mentioned before t-shirts
important make sure you get uh today
this last day to order uh don't forget
about next Sunday
um our time has changed to 11 and then
if you're a visitor here
um we do have like a there's a card
outside that front door off to the right
there's a table we'd love to get some
basic information from you just to say
thanks for being here
um and just to give you like a quick
shout out just saying how much we
appreciate you so if you wouldn't mind
feeling bad I would just like to have a
record of that
so with that being said
um if you'd like to stand you can do
that but like the City route with a
blessing
you are a child of God
and this is true on your best day
and it's true on your worst day
so as you go ahead with your weeks yet
to be determined highs and lows and
everything in between
go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved you are worthy and you were
accepted Just As You Are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with
have a great week